sorry for having 43 parties I have
certain teachers that are cool a little
bit like well you need help with this
and they'll like hold you after class
and help you out with stuff while others
they don't care they're just like okay
I'm here to teach get paid and leave
something I hate about teachers is that
sometimes they give too much homework or
they expect a lot but they don't really
give a good lesson
[Music]
on average how much the teachers spend
out-of-pocket in 2016 on supplies for
the classroom and the students I mean
like an elementary school we use like
crayons and markers in high school it's
basically all given to you I think 260
we really brought the supplies so I feel
like the middle for a yeah 488 Corey no
way I thought that the school gave them
everything I have a specific teacher who
she gets there at 6 o'clock in the
morning for help sessions until 8:00 and
then after school she stays there until
6 so that's like an extra two hours
she's there before and after school
she's not getting paid for it either but
she's just there to make sure a students
are succeeding in her class as of 2014
over what percent of public school
teachers in the u.s. work second job
outside of school I know that have paid
a lot yeah yeah thirty percent
I think 20% a twenty percent yeah yes no
yeah yeah almost what percentage of
teachers quit within five years of
studying a teaching career my teachers
from another ninety school it was like
one and done so they would do a year and
then they would leave maybe 20 percent
yeah see wow that's a lot maybe the
students are mean to them or give them a
hard time what percent of teachers are
affected by high stress levels on the
dog see yeah see seen anything presented
I think you'd see ninety-three percent
because I'm learning it's very stressful
and expensive yeah it makes me realize
how much teachers should put in and
sometimes they don't receive it from the
students all you hear is like oh I hate
school I don't want to do my homework
Beauvoir and like teachers maybe some of
them it's like their dream job to teach
and to like work in education and stuff
so it's kind of sad that students can be
rude sometimes like we should just you
know wake up and be happy that were you
know who'd be in class yeah
disrespecting Elsa
[Music]